Our next psychotherapy is based on the principles of operant and classical
conditioning, and that's behavioral treatments. Behavioral treatments are used
to treat a variety of disorders, from autism to ADHD, drug addiction, anxiety,
depression, phobias, even schizophrenia and intellectual disabilities.
>> And because this is Susan's area of expertise, I'm going to pass it over to her
for a little bit.
>> The first published study to demonstrate the use of behavioral principles in
treating psychological disorders was published in 1959 by Teodoro Ayllon and
Jack Michael, and it was titled The Psychiatric Nurse as a Behavioral Engineer.
Now, Jack Michael was actually on my masters and Ph.D committees, and he
continues to contribute important work in the field of behavior analysis, and
that includes both the experimental analysis of behavior and applied behavior
analysis. Now in this particular study, they demonstrated how you could use
Skinner's operant conditioning principles to decrease the symptoms of mental
disorders. In addition, this was the first study that actually started the
field of applied behavior analysis. So, let's look at ABA in more detail.